there was a university in Japan that
recently opened up their curriculum to
allow people to get a masters in ninja
studies and what ended up happening was
there's a 45 year old man who went to
that university in order to hear
studying history traditions and fighting
techniques of a ninja he is officially
the first man to have a master's in
ninja studies now did he even minor in
nerdism probably I'm not sure but yeah
that's the thing now good work for our
corporation I'm a ninja apparently he's
not a crime a mountain quietly because
you know yeah what's the curriculum how
do we know what they're not exactly we
just know that he has to study the
history of ninjas I guess where it
started how it progressed what they did
and then he had to learn some martial
arts I don't I don't really know exactly
where you go with that but it took him
two years and he has his master's well
you have to study ninjutsu which is
illegal and UFC because it's too deadly
have you ever in here in all your dead
times fighting jammer spar with a guy
was a kung fu guy also I like how that
ninjas out of shape yeah that's a good
point that's a small axe and off is that
a belt or this sweatshirt wrapped around
his waist now those are baggy pants
Brennan talk to him apparently he thinks
he lives in the 1500s he kind of looks
like an Asian Elon Musk yes okay I'll
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah
your tongue okay what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]